that the ceo of the drug and alcohol  addiction treatment center steps down  after allegations in a lawsuit by a  former employee as eight news now  reported friday the plaintiff accused  david marlin of sexual assault and  harassment she claims it happened over  the course of two months earlier this  year while marlin was her boss according  to crossroads of southern nevada marlin  is stepping down effective immediately a  statement reads in part we have a zero  tolerance harassment policy and will  continue to provide a safe environment  for all of our employees  and on friday marlin's attorney dominic  gentile issued a statement calling the  allegations false and the lawsuit a work  of fiction you can find both full  statements at eight newsnow dot com  along with more information about the  lawsuit itself and then tomorrow here on  eight news now at eleven o'clock the  i-team will have a full report